Travel to Africa. People from Africa sometimes told Eddy Harris that he looked like he might be from Senegal, instead of St. Louis where, in fact, he was from. And when he finally arrived at the border of Senegal, the first black nation he had ever set foot in, a man at the border found out that he was from America and, incredibly, told him, welcome home. We're glad you're here.
前往非洲。非洲人有时会告诉埃迪·哈里斯（Eddy Harris），他看起来像是塞内加尔人，而不是实际上出身的圣路易斯人。当他终于抵达塞内加尔边境——这是他踏上的第一个黑人国家——边境的一名男子发现他是美国人，竟不可思议地对他说：欢迎回家，我们很高兴你来到这里。
It was a pretty magical moment, and I was expecting it to have opened the door into everybody saying, welcome home, brother. And I got a lot of, welcome home, brother. But I also got a lot of, how come you didn't come sooner, brother? Or, what are you doing to help us, brother? You, who are the most educated and the richest black people on the planet, how come you're not doing more to help us out, brother?
那是一个相当神奇的时刻，我本以为这会开启一扇大门，让所有人都会说“欢迎回家，兄弟”。我也确实听到了很多声“欢迎回家，兄弟”。但我也听到了很多质问：“兄弟，你怎么没早点回来？”或者“兄弟，你为我们做了什么？身为地球上受教育程度最高、最富有的黑人，你怎么没多做点什么来帮助我们？”
As black Americans.
作为美国黑人。
As black Americans, yeah.
是的，作为美国黑人。
For Eddy, as for a lot of black Americans, Africa had always been this kind of lurking spectre somewhere in the back of his mind. There was this idea that there was some place out there that could be a motherland. And then, there was the reality of life in Africa. For nearly a year, he traveled through the continent, staying with local people, living how they lived, eating what they ate. And he was often horrified at the conditions of their lives-- the lack of food, the disease, infant mortality rates, one repressive political regime after another-- all often accepted with kind of God-will-provide attitude.
对于埃迪来说，就像许多美国黑人一样，非洲一直是他心头挥之不去的阴影。人们总有一种想法，认为那里有一个可以被称为祖国的地方。然而，非洲生活的现实却是另一回事。他在这片大陆上旅行了近一年，与当地人住在一起，过着他们的生活，吃着他们的食物。他常常对那里的生活状况感到惊恐——食物匮乏、疾病横行、婴儿死亡率高、独裁政权接二连三——而这一切通常都被视为一种“上帝自有安排”的态度所接受。
Anyway, it all came to a head at the end of his trip when he was on a boat going up a river in Zaire.
总之，这一切在他旅行结束时达到了高潮，当时他正坐船沿扎伊尔的一条河流而上。
There was this captain on this boat who, because I was taking pictures on the deck of this boat, had me and this English person, Justin, hauled up to the bridge. And while we were there, he was vilifying this white guy, this Englishman, because his ancestors had hauled my ancestors out of Africa. And he wanted to know why I wouldn't come to Africa to live and help build the place up. And he wanted to know, as well, how I could in good conscience, I suppose, live my life among these white people who had stolen my ancestors away.
船上有一位船长，因为我在甲板上拍照，就把我和那个叫贾斯汀（Justin）的英国人叫到了驾驶台。我们在那里的时候，他一直在谴责这个白人、这个英国人，因为他的祖先曾把我的祖先从非洲掳走。他想知道为什么我不愿来非洲生活并帮助建设这里。他还想知道，我究竟是怎么心安理得地生活在那些曾掳走我祖先的白人中间的。
And after having traveled in Africa already now for many, many months, and I was tired and exhausted and had lived this African experience and was just beat down, I turned to this white guy, Justin, and said thanks for his ancestors having stolen my ancestors. In in mind and in the eyes of black Americans, that's probably a horrible thing to say. Because what it sounds like is I'm grateful for slavery, which is not the case at all. What it says to me is that I'm grateful for being alive and for having grown up as a black person in America. I don't know if I'd want to trade places with anybody African living in the middle of Zaire.
在非洲旅行了许多个月后，我感到疲惫不堪，经历了这一切非洲体验后，我心力交瘁。我转过头对那个白人贾斯汀说，谢谢他祖先偷走了我的祖先。在许多美国黑人的心目中，这可能是一句可怕的话。因为听起来好像我感激奴隶制，但事实并非如此。我想表达的是，我感激自己还活着，感激自己作为一名黑人在美国长大。我不知道自己是否愿意和任何生活在扎伊尔腹地的非洲人交换身份。
Do you feel like there's a certain amount of pressure on black Americans to embrace Africa as a homeland?
你是否觉得美国黑人面临着一种压力，要认同非洲为祖国？
Yeah, and it's all around. And you're supposed to, as a black person, tow this black person party line and embrace Africa as your homeland, even though most black Americans haven't got a clue about Africa, no more clue about African than I had, no more clue about Africa than they've got about Antarctica. It's a faraway place that, if you dropped them off in the middle of no place and said, you're home now, they'd be completely lost. And yet, they're supposed to have this emotional allegiance to this place. And I can't buy it.
是的，到处都是。作为黑人，你被要求紧跟黑人阵营的政治路线，认同非洲是你的祖国。尽管大多数美国黑人对非洲一无所知，就像我当初一样，他们对非洲的了解甚至还不如对南极洲了解得多。那是一个遥远的地方，如果你把他们丢在荒郊野外，告诉他们“你到家了”，他们会彻底迷失。然而，他们却被要求对这个地方保持情感上的忠诚。我无法接受这一点。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This . American . Life . I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, Going Home to a Place You've Never Been. A lot of people try it.
这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。今天我们的节目主题是“回到从未去过的地方”。很多人尝试过这样做。
Act One, Exile. A 26-year-old from Los Angeles gets deported to the country of his parents' birth. He last set foot there when he was five. He has no memories of the place. He knows no one there. People have a hard time understanding him when he talks. This, he's told, is his new home.
第一幕：流放。一名26岁的洛杉矶青年被驱逐回他父母的出生国。他最后一次踏足那里是在五岁时。他没有任何关于那个地方的记忆，也不认识任何人。人们在和他交谈时很难理解他。但他被告知，这就是他的新家。
Act Two, Brothers From Another Mother, two stories of people finding strangers who they become convinced are, in some way, the home they've never known. Stay with us, won't you?
第二幕：异母兄弟。讲述两个故事：人们发现了一些陌生人，并开始坚信他们以某种方式成了自己从未了解过的“家”。请继续收听。
Act One, Exile. In 1996, tough new immigration laws were passed making it easier to deport legal US residents who committed crimes. The law expanded the definition of a deportable crime. It made the change retroactive. Gang members from the United States were suddenly being exported in larger numbers to their countries of birth. And many of them greeted these new homes away from home by acting exactly how they had acted here in the States. There have been big, big rises in gang activity in El Salvador and other countries as a result of the new laws.
第一幕：流放。1996年，美国通过了严厉的新移民法，使得遣返犯罪的美国合法居民变得更容易。法律扩大了可遣返犯罪的定义，并具有追溯力。来自美国的帮派成员突然被大量驱逐回他们的出生国。他们中的许多人以在这边做派一样的方式，向这些“异国他乡”的新家报到。由于这些新法律，萨尔瓦多和其他国家的帮派活动出现了巨大的增长。
Jose William Huezo Soriano-- aka Weasel-- was deported just over a year ago to El Salvador. He had to make the adjustment from living in a very rich country to a rather poor one. And he had to figure out who to be in this place that he was told was his new home. Radio producer Joe Richman gave him a tape recorder to document how he's getting along. Here's the story they put together.
何塞·威廉·韦佐·索里亚诺（Jose William Huezo Soriano）——绰号“黄鼠狼”（Weasel）——在大约一年前被驱逐回萨尔瓦多。他不得不从一个非常富裕的国家搬到一个相当贫穷的国家。他必须弄清楚在被告知是“新家”的这个地方，他到底该是谁。电台制作人乔·里奇曼（Joe Richman）给了他一台录音机，记录他的生活状态。这是他们共同整理的故事。
What's up? My name is Jose William Huezo Soriano. They call me Weasel. I've been having that nickname ever since I was a kid, so I've had it for a long time.
怎么了？我叫何塞·威廉·韦佐·索里亚诺。他们叫我“黄鼠狼”。我从小就有这个绰号，所以我用这个名字很久了。
Here we go, I'm dialing out of the country right now, 0-1-8-1-8-5-0.
开始了，我正在拨打国际长途，0-1-8-1-8-5-0。
I'm 27 years old. I live in El Salvador. I've been here a year, a year and a half. It's ringing.
我27岁，住在萨尔瓦多。我来这儿有一年、一年半了。通了。
Hello?
喂？
Hello.
喂。
Hi.
嗨。
Flora, what's up?
弗洛拉，怎么了？
Not much. How are you doing?
没什么，你怎么样？
I'm doing good.
我很好。
My goodness. Where are you?
天哪，你在哪儿？
I'm in El Salvador. Where else? I just wanted to talk to mom and see how she's doing.
我在萨尔瓦多，还能在哪儿？我只是想和妈妈说说话，看看她怎么样。
Here she is. Hold on.
她在这儿，等一下。
All right.
好的。
My mom is cool, man. My mom's name is Esther. Esthaire. And I have her name tattooed on me, like with a little rose.
我妈很棒，真的。我妈叫埃丝特（Esther）。埃丝特。我把她的名字纹在了身上，旁边还有一朵小玫瑰。
Hi, mijo.
嗨，我的孩子（mijo）。
Mom!
妈妈！
Como esta, mi hijito?
我的小儿子（mi hijito），你好吗？
Bien, mom. Y como estas, mom?
很好，妈妈。你怎么样，妈妈？
Yo estoy bien. [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
我很好。[语音模糊]。
I'm the youngest of seven kids. I come from a close-knit family. We're used to being around each other. My mom's in LA. She lives in Burbank. My sister's in Burbank. All my nieces and nephews are in Burbank. My brother's in North Hollywood. And here I am.
我是家里七个孩子中最小的。我来自一个紧密的家庭，我们习惯在一起。我妈妈在洛杉矶，住在伯班克。我妹妹也在伯班克。我所有的侄子侄女都在伯班克。我哥哥在北好莱坞。而我却在这里。
She's telling me she likes me to call her up and tell her that I'm doing all right, because then she feels all right.
她告诉我她喜欢我给她打电话，告诉她我过得还不错，因为那样她才会安心。
Bueno, mom. Ya me voy, OK? Te quiero mucho.
好吧，妈妈。我得挂了，好吗？我非常爱你。
Esta bien, verdad?
你还好吗，真的？
Estoy muy bien, mom.
我很好，妈妈。
OK, si. I love you, mijo.
好的，是的。我爱你，孩子。
I love you, mom.
我也爱你，妈妈。
OK, mi amor. I love you, mi amor.
好的，我的爱人。我爱你，我的爱人。
OK, bye.
好的，再见。
I've got this document right here. It says my full name, and it has a little box right here that's checked. And it says deportable under section blah, blah, blah. Remove from the States. Anyway, the bottom line is that I've been banished from the US, like they used to do in the Medieval days. They used to ban fools.
我手里有这份文件。上面写着我的全名，这儿有个小方框勾选了。上面写着根据第某某某节可被驱逐。从美国除名。不管怎样，结论就是我被美国放逐了，就像中世纪时期那样。他们以前放逐傻瓜。
I went to kindergarten in LA, elementary school, junior high school, high school. I grew up singing "My Country, 'Tis of Thee," that song, "America The Beautiful." I learned pledging allegiance to the flag. I grew up with all that. Here they are, 20-some years later, kicking me out.
我在洛杉矶上的幼儿园、小学、初中、高中。我唱着《我的祖国》和《美丽的亚美利加》长大。我学会了向国旗宣誓。我是在这一切中长大的。结果20多年后，他们把我踢了出来。
OK, we're en route to San Jacinto. This is the number five bus. We're going to downtown. These are old school buses from the United States that they send over here, paint them up, and they use them for public transportation. Everybody's looking at me weird because I'm wearing glasses, headphones, I've got this microphone. I'm just looking at the people, all the little shacks. There's these little shacks on the side of the road. It's a trip right here.
好的，我们正在去圣哈辛托的路上。这是5号巴士。我们要去市中心。这些都是从美国送过来的旧校车，漆上颜色后，被当作公共交通工具使用。每个人都用奇怪的眼神看着我，因为我戴着眼镜、耳机，还拿着麦克风。我正看着人们，看着那些简陋的小棚屋。路边都是这种小屋。这里真是一趟奇妙的旅程。
Well, maybe I should tell you a little bit about when I first got here. Damn, as I was driving to the city from the airport, it was hot. I would just look to the side and see little adobe huts, shacks. And I was like, no, I ain't staying here, man. This is crazy, man. I ain't going to live in no mud hut. It was like if they sent me back, like, 200 years. I was like, they might as well have put me on Mars.
好吧，也许我该说说我刚来这儿的时候。该死，当我从机场开车去市区时，天气很热。我往窗外看，看到的是土坯房和棚屋。我当时想：不，我不会留在这儿的，这太疯狂了。我可不住这种泥屋。感觉就像他们把我送回了200年前。我觉得他们干脆把我扔到火星上算了。
We're pulling over now. OK, here we are. We're in San Jacinto already. These streets we're walking on, this is where I first came when I got deported. I didn't know anybody know in Salvador because all my relatives are in the United States. So I got ahold of one of my dad's distant cousins that he hadn't seen for 10, 20 years. She gave me a break and let me stay here.
我们要靠边停车了。好了，我们到了。我们已经在圣哈辛托了。这些我正走着的街道，就是我刚被驱逐时来的地方。我在萨尔瓦多谁也不认识，因为我所有的亲戚都在美国。所以我联系到了我爸爸的一个远房表亲，他已经10、20年没见过她了。她帮了我一把，让我住在这里。
Hola. Como esta, tio? Gordito. Hola.
你好。叔叔好。胖乎乎。你好。
When I first got here, everybody thought I was a weirdo. They didn't even believe I was from here because I had such a tough time speaking Spanish. I speak Spanish, but a different Spanish, you know?
我刚到这里时，大家都觉得我是个怪人。他们甚至不相信我是本地人，因为我的西班牙语说得很糟糕。我确实会说西班牙语，但那是另一种西班牙语，你懂的。
We're walking in the door. I stayed in that room right there. It was like a storage room. I'll open this door here.
我们进门了。我当时就住在那个房间里，那像个杂物间。我把这门打开。
[SPEAKING SPANISH] Man, there's no light here.
[西班牙语] 天哪，这里没灯。
When I first got here, I looked at the place where I was going to stay, and I said, this is it. Because I walked in and all I seen was pieces of wood nailed together. The house was made out of concrete, but it was all dark. The toilet was in the middle the yard. It was like a little outhouse. It was just nothing I was used to.
我刚来时，看着我住的地方，心想：这就是全部了。因为我走进去看到的全是钉在一起的木板。房子是水泥盖的，但里面黑漆漆的。厕所就在院子中间，像个小茅房。这根本不是我习惯的生活。
I spent the night in this room. The first day I was there, I had almost fallen asleep, and a big old cockroach-- that sucker had to be at least three inches-- fell right on my chest. And I  just jumped up. I grabbed at it, and I just threw it. And I heard it-- that's how big it was-- I heard that sucker fly across the room, boom, hit a wall, and I heard that sucker actually run away. It was a trip, man.
我在这房间里过了一夜。第一天我在那儿时，快睡着了，一只大蟑螂——那混蛋至少有三英寸大——直接掉在我胸口上。我跳了起来，抓住它扔了出去。我听见它飞过房间的声音，咚地撞在墙上，我还真听见那混蛋跑掉了。这真是太离谱了。
When I was in the, I think, third, fourth grade, my teacher sent me to get an IQ test, and they recognized me as gifted and talented. My parents telling me, you're intelligent. You're going to be a doctor or lawyer. But things happen when you're growing up. You get caught up in other things.
记得我大概在三、四年级的时候，老师让我参加智商测试，他们认定我是天才儿童。我父母对我说，你很聪明，以后会成为医生或律师。但成长过程中总会发生些变故，你会陷入其他事情。
My criminal history started when I was a juvenile. I'm kind of a short guy. I'm not too tall. But I was a little tough kid. I got into a gang when I was, like, 14 years old. I was into drugs and violence and stuff, auto burglary. I was living a crazy life.
我的犯罪史始于青少年时期。我个子不高，但我曾是个硬气的孩子。我14岁左右加入了帮派。我开始接触毒品、暴力之类的事，还有偷车。我过着疯狂的生活。
So I was just hanging out with my homeboys one day, and I had a little gun, took it-- a little .25, I think it was, .22. I don't know. We were cruising in this neighborhood and seen some people. The driver pulled over, me and the other guy walked out, went up to the people, told them, It's not worth it, man. Give it up. So they gave it up, their wallets, their purses, watches.
有一天我和哥们儿闲逛时，我有一把小枪，应该是.25口径或者是.22。我不知道。我们在那个街区兜风，看见了一些人。司机靠边停车，我和另一个人下车走向他们，对他们说：不值得，老兄，交出来吧。于是他们交出了钱包、手提包和手表。
So we took off, went to go pawn the stuff. But as we were leaving the pawn shop, boom, the cops swooped on us, drew their guns, put us all face down in the middle of the street. Helicopter, in front of everybody, big old scene. Took us in. Gave me three years in prison.
我们逃跑了，准备去把东西典当掉。但当我们离开当铺时，砰的一声，警察包围了我们，掏出枪，把我们全都脸朝地按在马路中间。直升机、众目睽睽之下，场面很大。他们把我们带走了，判了我三年监禁。
Anyway, right when my time was about to finish in prison, I was out in the yard playing handball. They came and called me. An INS agent came to visit me. And I didn't think nothing of it, because I thought he was just going to ask me, where's your green card or where's your papers?
总之，就在我快服完刑时，我正在院子里打手球。他们过来叫我，移民局的探员来找我。我没多想，因为我以为他只是要问我绿卡在哪里或者证件在哪里。
So he interviewed me to prove I was El Salvadorian. They said, what's the national anthem? I was like, man, I don't know. What's the biggest river? I was like, what? I told them, look, man, I don't know nothing about El Salvador. I've been in this country for over 20 years, man. I don't know nothing about that country. He was all pissed off because I didn't know what the biggest river was. I grew up in LA. Longest river there is the LA River.
他面试我是为了证明我是萨尔瓦多人。他们问我：国歌是什么？我说：老兄，我不知道。什么是最大的河流？我说：什么？我对他们说：听着，老兄，我对萨尔瓦多一无所知。我在这个国家住了20多年了，我对那个国家一无所知。他很生气，因为我不知道那条最大的河是什么。我是在洛杉矶长大的。那里最长的河是洛杉矶河。
Anyway, the bottom line is that they said they seen a pattern of criminal history and criminal activity. They felt like there was no chance for me, that I couldn't change. And that's why they deported me.
总之，重点是他们说他们看到了我的犯罪史和犯罪活动的模式。他们觉得我没救了，觉得我无法改变。这就是他们驱逐我的原因。
The longest river here is Rio Lempa, the Lempa River, and it goes all through El Salvador. Well, I know that now.
这里最长的河是伦帕河（Rio Lempa），它贯穿整个萨尔瓦多。好吧，我现在知道了。
Right now, we're driving through, making some bus stops. This is MS territory. And about four or five blocks down, we're going to enter a different gang territory. This is a little paragraph in a tour guide book. It says On Your Own in El Salvador. And there's a little paragraph here that's kind of highlighted. And it says, "Gang trouble. Gang violence in cities like LA and New York has spurred the US government to deport many of its worst offenders back to their native countries. For some Salvadorans with a history of violence and arrest, that means a return trip to El Salvador."
现在我们正在开车，中途停了几站。这是MS帮派的地盘。再走四五个街区，我们就要进入另一个帮派的地盘了。旅游指南里有一小段话，标题是“在萨尔瓦多独自旅行”。其中有一小段被高亮了，上面写着：“帮派麻烦。洛杉矶和纽约等城市的帮派暴力促使美国政府将许多最严重的罪犯驱逐回他们的祖国。对于一些有暴力和逮捕记录的萨尔瓦多人来说，这意味着被送回萨尔瓦多。”
So this is in the guidebook. I feel like I'm a tourist, a permanent one.
所以手册里写的就是这样。我觉得自己像个游客，一个永久的游客。
We're at this place. There's Mexican food called Que Taco Garabato. I've tried the tortas here. They're excellent. I recommend them a lot. I'm going to try a quesadilla today. [SPEAKING SPANISH]
我们到了这个地方。有一家墨西哥餐馆叫Que Taco Garabato。我尝过这里的塔科饼，太棒了，强烈推荐。今天我要试试玉米饼。 [西班牙语]
Now that I accepted the fact that I have to stay here, I've started changing a few things. I've had a lot of help from my family, my cousins. They make furniture here. They're carpenters by trade. I work with them for no pay. I don't mind, considering the fact that I was a criminal, and I got deported, and they had heard a little bit about my past. Considering all that, they still let me stay. And I really appreciate it. But now I live out on my own.
现在我接受了必须留在这里的事实，我开始改变了一些事情。我从家人和表亲那里得到了很多帮助。他们在这里做家具，是木匠。我给他们打下手，没拿工资。考虑到我曾是个罪犯，还被驱逐出境，而他们也听说过我的过去，他们依然让我住下，我真的很感激。不过现在我一个人住了。
The food's here. A little chile right there. Damn, the food looks delicious. When I came back here, I remembered a few things, like foods that I hadn't smelled or tasted for years. And I tried it, and I'd go, hey, I know this flavor. Bam, I remember this flavor when I was a kid. It's like trying to remember a dream. It's fuzzy. You only remember little pieces.
食物来了。那儿有一点辣椒。该死，食物看起来太美味了。当我回到这里时，我想起了一些东西，比如那些我多年没闻过或尝过的味道。我尝了一口，心想：嘿，我知道这个味道。砰，我想起小时候吃过的这个味道。就像试图回忆一个梦，它是模糊的，你只记得其中的碎片。
As you can see, I'm talking with my mouth full. We'll take a little break here, savor the delicacies, get back at you in a few minutes. Out.
如你所见，我正塞着满嘴东西说话。我们要在这休息一下，享受一下美味，几分钟后再回来。结束。
Where I live right now, actually, it's a good-looking place. It's got a high ceiling. It's pretty big. My room. I had it all painted. I did some graffiti-style spray paint. Artistic stuff. Anyway, right now, I'm just playing some music. Pedro Infante is a Mexican ranchera singer. My dad, he used to like Pedro Infante. There's just something about the music that brings back a lot of memories.
我现在住的地方其实还不错。天花板很高，空间很大。我的房间，我把它全涂了。我用喷漆画了涂鸦风格的东西，很有艺术感。总之，我现在正在放音乐。佩德罗·因方特（Pedro Infante）是一位墨西哥牧歌歌手。我爸爸以前很喜欢他。这音乐里总有些什么东西能带回许多回忆。
I've got a little black photo album in front of me right here. Here's a picture of me in fifth grade. I had long hair. I had a Pink Floyd shirt on. I'm wearing Vans, Levis. Here's a picture of my brother and I skateboarding. We had a half-pipe in my backyard. Some memories, you know?
我面前有一本黑色的小相册。这是我五年级时的照片，留着长发，穿着平克·弗洛伊德的衬衫，穿着Vans鞋和Levis牛仔裤。这是我和我哥哥滑板的照片，我们在后院有个U型池。很多回忆，你懂的。
I guess my closest relationship that I had would be with my brother. He's six years older than me, and he took care of me a lot. I remember this one time we were hanging out, and there was these two real pretty girls. And my brother was already a teenager. He was trying to make out with this girl.
我想我最亲近的人应该是我哥哥。他比我大六岁，他很照顾我。记得有一次我们在外面玩，有两个很漂亮的女孩。我哥哥已经是青少年了，他正试着亲那个女孩。
And I liked her friend. So I tried to do the same thing my brother did. So I tried to kiss the girl, and she popped me in the mouth and busted my lip, and I started crying. I remember my brother, he was hugging me, holding me, telling me, hey, shh, be quiet, be quiet, c'mon. Cleaning the blood off my lip with his shirt.
我喜欢她的朋友，于是我试着做和我哥一样的事。我试图亲那个女孩，结果她给了我一拳，打破了我的嘴唇，我哭了起来。我记得我哥哥紧紧抱着我，安慰我，说：嘿，嘘，安静点，安静点，走吧。他用衬衫帮我擦掉了嘴唇上的血。
I don't know. For some reason, I always thought I was smarter than my brother. I spoke better English. I had better skills, like math skills. But my brother, he always did the right thing. My brother's an LA sheriff. And me, I'm the convict. He did good things. I did bad things. My brother joined the army. I joined the gang.
我不知道。出于某种原因，我一直以为自己比哥哥聪明。我英语说得更好，数学也更好。但我哥哥总是做正确的事。我哥哥是洛杉矶的治安官，而我呢，我是罪犯。他做了好事，我做了坏事。我哥哥参了军，我加入了帮派。
Que paso?
怎么了（Que paso）？
What's up?
什么事？
What's this [? again ?] called?
这首歌叫什么？
I don't know the name of it.
我不知道名字。
Hey, you got Beatles here? All right. We're going to play The Beatles right now. It's a little loud. Got the Beatles playing in the background. Just relaxing right here in the billiards. Brand-new billiards. There's fluorescent lights. It's cool, man. It's like a place in the United States. Chalk? Where's the chalk at?
嘿，你们这里有披头士的歌？太好了。我们现在要放披头士。声音有点大。背景里放着披头士。就在这台台球桌旁放松。崭新的台球桌。这儿有荧光灯。太酷了，伙计。就像美国的地方。粉笔呢？粉笔在哪里？
Where's the chalk? I don't know.
粉笔在哪里？我不知道。
Well, when I first got here, I didn't know anybody. So one day, I seen two guys in the distance dressed LA-style, like, baggy. And I said, those guys ain't from here. Right off the [? back, ?] I knew they weren't from here. As he got closer I said, damn, I know that fool. He looks familiar. And he got closer, and I said, yep, that's him. And I told him, what's up, fool?
好吧，我刚来的时候谁也不认识。所以有一天，我在远处看到两个穿着洛杉矶风格、裤管很大的人。我说，那两个家伙不是这儿的人。一眼就能看出来，我知道他们不是本地人。他走近时我说，该死，我认识那个傻瓜。他看起来很面熟。他走得更近了，我说，没错，就是他。我对他说：怎么了，傻瓜？
And he looks at me, he's like, "damn!" He couldn't stop saying damn. He was just like, "damn, what's up, man?" He goes, "You're from here?" I said, "Yeah, man. I got deported, man." He's like, "Damn, me too, man, What up? Damn."
他看着我，说：该死！他不停地说“该死”。他就是说：该死，怎么了老兄？他说：你也是这儿的人？我说：是啊老兄，我被驱逐了。他说：该死，我也是老兄。怎么回事？该死。
I see you've got a couple of tattoos. You've got one on your arm, like by your elbow. What does that say right there?
我看到你有几个纹身。你的手臂上，胳膊肘旁边有一个。那写的是什么？
Pokey rest in peace.
“Pokey”安息吧。
I see you've got a really nice one on your leg. Some real good work. Who did that work? Just kidding. I did it. They make you dress like this to go to work?
我看到你腿上有一个很漂亮的纹身。做工真好。那是谁做的？开玩笑的，是我自己做的。他们让你穿成这样去上班？
Well, they don't make me, and the way I like it, the way I dress, you've got to change your style sometimes. A little bit classic, white, long-sleeved shirt--
嗯，他们没强迫我。但我喜欢我穿衣的风格，有时你需要改变一下自己的风格。经典的白长袖衬衫——
I've ran into other guys I know from prison. They're doing all right. There's Edgar. He did some prison time. He got deported. Alex. Frank. Rabbit. It didn't matter that he had kids that were US citizens. They deported him anyway. They split up his family. Ringo has kids, too. A little daughter. They're like my second family.
我遇到过其他我认识的狱友。他们都过得还行。有埃德加，他在监狱待过，被驱逐了。还有亚历克斯、弗兰克、拉比特。他有身为美国公民的孩子也没用，他们还是驱逐了他，拆散了他的家庭。林戈也有孩子，一个小女儿。他们就像我的第二个家庭。
We're out in the main street now, walking by the mariachis here. We're going to go see what that's like right now.
我们现在在大街上，走过这些玛利亚奇乐手。我们要去看看那是什么样。
Here the come, watch out.
他们来了，小心点。
Here they come. Aw, you did it now, man. Chiquita, chiquita.
他们来了。噢，你这下搞砸了，老兄。小乖乖，小乖乖。
It's weird, but in a way, I'm glad I'm not in LA. Over there in Los Angeles, a lot of guys are dead, they're life in prison, or just lost in drugs. I feel lucky because I'm alive still. I'm just through with that lifestyle. I'm doing good. I'm working. I'm doing the best I've ever done in my life. I feel more alive now. I woke up. I just snapped out of it. I feel like I've been given a second chance.
很奇怪，但在某种程度上，我很高兴我不在洛杉矶。在洛杉矶，很多人要么死了，要么在坐牢，要么沉迷于毒品。我觉得自己很幸运，因为我还活着。我彻底摆脱了那种生活方式。我过得很好，在工作。我正在过我一生中最好的日子。我觉得现在更有活力了。我醒悟了，我从那种状态里跳了出来。我感觉自己得到了第二次机会。
Here I am in my living room. I got this video. It's a tape that my family recorded. Let's see what's on here. There's Burbank, where we live. I see the main street right there, Victory. The apartments where my mom lives, and my sister lives next door. I'm going to turn up the volume a little bit. There goes my mom. She's smiling all goofy, making faces at the camera. She's all nervous. She doesn't know what to say.
我正坐在客厅里。我有个视频，是我家人录的一盘带子。看看里面有什么。那是我们住的伯班克。我看到了主干道——胜利大道。我妈妈住的公寓，我妹妹就住在隔壁。我要把音量调大一点。看，我妈妈在那儿。她笑得很傻，对着镜头做鬼脸。她很紧张，不知道该说什么。
My mom says that she sends me hugs and kisses and that she loves me, she misses me. I haven't seen my mom for over a year, year and a half. I know I'm going to see her soon, but as for me to go live with her and just be around her, that's impossible now. I imagine it, seeing my mom, hugging her, feeling the love that she generates. Damn. Having a meal with her, talking to her, laughing with her, seeing my family.
我妈妈说她送我拥抱和吻，她很爱我，很想我。我有一年多、一年半没见过我妈妈了。我知道我很快会见到她，但要让我回去和她住在一起，待在她身边，这现在是不可能的。我幻想过那个场景：见到妈妈，拥抱她，感受她给予的爱。该死。和她一起吃饭，和她说话，和她大笑，见见我的家人。
I'll be 47 years old by the time I'm eligible to go back. 47, man. I don't think I might even want to go back at that age. My mom ain't going to live no-- she's 66 right now. She's not going to live no 20 years, man. It's [BLEEP] up.
我等到有资格回美国时都47岁了。47岁啊，伙计。到了那个年纪，我可能都不想回去了。我妈妈活不了那么久——她现在66岁了。她活不了20年了，伙计。这真是烂透了。
We miss you.
我们想念你。
I love you, I miss you. Call me. I'll see you soon.
我爱你，我想你。给我打电话。很快见。
I'll see you soon, man.
很快见，老兄。
And that was the end of the tape. Everybody's happy in the video. They're all telling me they miss me, they love me. That's really good to hear once in a while, especially if it's pre-recorded. You could always play it again and again.
带子录完了。视频里每个人都很开心。他们都在告诉我他们想我，他们爱我。偶尔听到这些真的很好，尤其是录好的视频。你可以一遍又一遍地播放。
Well, got a few minutes left before I close. I just want to say, what's up to all my familia, let you all know that I'm thinking of you. And I don't want you guys to worry because I'm living good here. I love you, Mom. I miss you, and I know you're proud of me. That's about it. I'm signing out. It's a wrap.
好吧，离结束还有几分钟。我只想说，跟我所有的家人打个招呼，让你们知道我在想你们。你们不用担心，因为我在这里过得很好。我爱你，妈妈。我很想你，我知道你为我感到骄傲。差不多就是这样。我要下线了，结束了。
These days, Weasel's job is working with an organization in San Salvador called Homies Unidos. He's their treasurer. The group is made up of current and former gang members who are working to reduce gang violence in El Salvador.
这些天，“黄鼠狼”在圣萨尔瓦多一家名为“Homies Unidos”的组织工作，他是该组织的财务主管。该组织由现任和前任帮派成员组成，他们正致力于减少萨尔瓦多的帮派暴力。
Weasel wanted to dedicate this radio story to his friend at Homies Unidos, Ringo, who was mentioned in the story, actually, and was shot and killed in El Salvador last week. Weasel's diary was reported and narrated by Jose William Huezo Soriano, that is, by Weasel. The story was produced by Joe Richman as part of the Radio Diaries series, with help from Wendy Dorr.
“黄鼠狼”想把这个电台故事献给他“Homies Unidos”的朋友林戈（Ringo），就是故事中提到的那位。他其实在上周于萨尔瓦多被枪杀。关于“黄鼠狼”的日记是由何塞·威廉·韦佐·索里亚诺本人记录并讲述的。该故事由乔·里奇曼制作，属于《广播日记》（Radio Diaries）系列，温迪·多尔（Wendy Dorr）提供了协助。
[MUSIC--"CALIFORNIA GIRLS" BY BEACH BOYS]
[音乐——海滩男孩的《加州女孩》]
Coming up, a photograph spotted by chance in a country other than the one in which it was taken, a man named Irving met one spring night in a living room, and how these random encounters push people's lives through 180-degree turns. That's in a minute, from Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，一个偶然在其他国家发现的照片，一个名叫欧文的男人在某个春夜的客厅里相遇。以及这些随机的邂逅如何将人们的生活推向180度的转折。一分钟后，来自国际公共广播电台的节目继续为您播出。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of stories on that theme. Today's program, Going Home to the Place You've Never Been. Up until now on our program, we've heard stories of people who ended up in foreign countries that they'd been told was their motherland. But it didn't really feel like home when they got there.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们都会选择一个主题，为你带来各种相关的报道。今天的节目主题是“回到从未去过的地方”。节目进行到现在，我们听到了人们最终到达了被告知是“祖国”的异国他乡，但他们到达那里后却并没有感受到“家”的感觉。
In this half of the program, we hear from people who stumbled upon a place where they instantly and instinctively felt more at home than in their real homes. We've arrived at Act Two. Act Two, Brothers From Another Mother.
在节目的下半部分，我们将听到一些人偶然走进了一个地方，在那里他们即时且本能地感到比在真正的家里更像回到了家。现在进入第二幕。第二幕：异母兄弟。
As Stephen Dubner a writes in his memoir, Turbulent Souls , he was raised in a big Catholic family in Upstate New York, youngest of eight kids, altar boy in church. And one year, after he went away to college, a student was giving him a ride back to his mother's during spring break. And they stopped at a house on the way. The driver announced that they were going to stop for two days to attend his grandfather's 80th birthday party. And Stephen found himself in this house full of strangers.
正如斯蒂芬·杜布纳（Stephen Dubner）在他的回忆录《动荡的灵魂》（Turbulent Souls）中所写，他在纽约州北部的一个大家庭长大，天主教徒，家中八个孩子里最小的一个，曾是教堂的祭坛侍从。一年他上大学后，在春假回家的路上，一位同学载了他一程，中途在一个房子停了下来。司机宣布他们要停两天，参加他祖父的80岁生日派对。斯蒂芬发现自己身处这栋住满陌生人的屋子里。
And the night before the party, I was staying there, and there was this other family staying there. And there was this guy named Irving with his wife and two children. Irving said to me-- they said that they were from Brooklyn, that they had flown down from Brooklyn. And I said, "Oh, my parents are from Brooklyn."
派对前夜，我住在那儿，还有另一个家庭也住在那儿。有一个叫欧文的人和他妻子及两个孩子。欧文对我说——他们说他们来自布鲁克林，是从布鲁克林飞过来的。我说：“哦，我父母也是布鲁克林人。”
He said, "whereabouts?" And I said, "I don't know. I think my mother lives somewhere near Ebbets Field." He said, "you've never been back? You've never been back to visit your bubba?" I said, "What's a bubba?"
他问：“具体哪儿？”我说：“我不知道。我想我妈妈住的地方靠近埃贝茨球场（Ebbets Field）。”他说：“你从没回去过吗？你从来没回去看过你的外婆（bubba）吗？”我说：“什么是外婆？”
And he looked at me, he said, "Aren't you Jewish?" And I said, "Well, no." I said, "But now that you mention it, my parents were both Jewish, and then they both became Catholic." And when I said that, he looked at me like I was a freak.
他看着我问：“你不是犹太人吗？”我说：“嗯，不是。”我说：“但你提到这个，我父母本来都是犹太人，后来都改信了天主教。”当我这么说时，他看我的眼神就像看怪物一样。
For some reason, I was very relaxed with this family. And we were hanging out in this place where I had no idea why I was there, what I was doing there. And I started playing piano, and we played and played, and they sang. I played, they sang.
出于某种原因，我和这家人在一起感到非常放松。我们待在一个我完全不知道为什么会去的地方。我开始弹钢琴，我们一直弹，他们唱歌。我弹奏，他们歌唱。
And he said, "Well, you sure play the piano like you're Jewish." I said, "Is that a good thing or a bad thing?" He said, "From where I sit, that's a good thing." And I felt this connection with Irving and his family like I'd kind of never felt before. It was a level of comfort that was very odd. For me to be a weird, shy teenager, in a place that I was uncomfortable, with people I'd never met, to be relaxed enough to hang out all night and play the piano with them and sing songs that were essentially silly, there was level of relaxation that went beyond-- it's like what you want your family to be.
他说：“好吧，你弹钢琴的样子确实像犹太人。”我说：“这是好事还是坏事？”他说：“在我看来，这是好事。”我与欧文和他家人产生了一种前所未有的联系感。那是一种非常奇特的舒适感。对于一个古怪、害羞的青少年来说，在一个我不舒服的地方，和从未谋面的人在一起，却能放松到彻夜狂欢，和他们一起弹琴唱歌，唱着本质上很傻的歌，那种放松感超越了……就像你想要的家人的感觉。
I think there was something that-- I'm scared to call it genetic, and it's obviously something more than some kind of cultural fingerprint-- but there was something in the way that Irving looked at the world and the people in it, and there was a manner about him that relaxed my genes a little bit. And it's one of those inexplicable things that is very real. It's like love, I guess, right? You can't define it, and you can't bottle it, and you can't turn it into an equation, but you know how much it either hurts or makes you feel good. And this was exactly like that.
我觉得有些东西——我不敢说这是遗传的，显然这不仅仅是一种文化指纹——但欧文看待世界和人的方式，他那种待人接物的方式，让我基因里某种东西放松了下来。这是那些无法解释但又非常真实的事情之一。就像爱情，对吧？你无法定义它，无法将它装进瓶子里，也无法将其变成一个等式，但你知道它让你感到多痛苦或多愉悦。这完全就是那种感觉。
This is precisely the sort of not-easy-to-explain experience that changes people's lives. And it changed Stephen's. Later, he looked back on it as the turning point that led him to converting to Judaism, which brings us to our next story. A Hungarian journalist who was passing through the States told us about this one, and went out with a tape recorder here in Chicago to do the interviews for our program. Her name is Anna Lengyel.
这正是那种难以解释、却改变人生的经历。它改变了斯蒂芬。后来他回顾时，认为这是他转而信仰犹太教的转折点。这也引出了我们的下一个故事。一位路过美国的匈牙利记者告诉我们这个故事，并带着录音机在芝加哥完成了采访。她的名字叫安娜·连格耶尔（Anna Lengyel）。
The story is about two people who had exactly the same kind of irrational moment of recognition that Stephen Dubner experienced. They simply decided, at some point, that they had more in common with each other than either one of them had with anyone else. The story begins with a woman named Ida, who was born in Poland during the Second World War to a Jewish family. When the Nazis invaded Poland and started shipping Jews off to concentration camps, she was separated from her family, including from her twin brother, Adam.
这个故事讲述了两个人，他们经历了与斯蒂芬·杜布纳一模一样的、非理性的认同时刻。他们只是在某个时刻决定，他们彼此之间的共同点比与任何其他人的共同点都要多。故事的主角是一个叫艾达（Ida）的女人，她在二战期间的波兰出生于一个犹太家庭。当纳粹入侵波兰并开始将犹太人运往集中营时，她与家人分开了，包括她的双胞胎兄弟亚当。
A Christian family took her in and pretended that she was their child until after the war, when her father tracked her down and retrieved her. They searched for the rest of their family, but they never found them. And long after she moved to the United States-- to Chicago-- she couldn't get over the feeling that her twin brother was still alive, out there somewhere. She found that she was always thinking about him, imagining what she would say to him when she saw him again. It was kind of a compulsion.
一个基督教家庭收留了她，并假装她是他们的孩子，直到战后她的父亲追寻到她并将她带回。他们寻找其余家人，但从未找到。在移居美国芝加哥很久之后，她仍无法摆脱一种感觉，即她的双胞胎兄弟还活着，就在某处的某个地方。她发现自己总是想起他，想象着见到他时该说些什么。这成了一种强迫症。
Whenever I went to another city or another country, the first thing I would do is pick up the telephone book and search for his name, Paluch. But I had no luck. There were Paluch, but they were not Jewish, or another country. They were maybe Italian or French or whatever. Wherever I went, I looked in the telephone book.
每当我到另一个城市或另一个国家时，我做的第一件事就是拿起电话簿搜索他的名字——帕卢赫（Paluch）。但我运气不好。确实有叫帕卢赫的，但他们不是犹太人，或者来自其他国家。他们可能是意大利人、法国人等等。无论我去哪里，我都查电话簿。
I was looking for family almost for my whole life.
我几乎用了一辈子在寻找家人。
While Ida was searching, there was a man in Poland named Jerzy Dolebski. He grew up in a Christian family, but he never felt right in his family. He says his parents never showed him the affection they gave to their other children. Like Ida, he told his story to Hungarian journalist Anna Lengyel.
当艾达在寻找时，波兰有一个名叫耶日·多莱布斯基（Jerzy Dolebski）的男人。他在一个基督教家庭长大，但在那个家里他从未感到自在。他说父母从未像对其他孩子那样对他表现出爱意。像艾达一样，他把故事告诉了匈牙利记者安娜·连格耶尔。
I was thinking, what going on? Because I saw other kids, they are kissing my parents. They walk in Sunday together. I never. My responsibility was only clean yards around home. Clean shoes for everybody.
我心想，怎么回事？因为我看到其他孩子，他们亲吻父母。周日他们一起散步。我从来没有。我的责任只是清理房子周围的院子，帮所有人擦鞋。
Were you badly treated?
你受虐待了吗？
Yes, my Polish parents treated me like that. And they told me, this is for your best.
是的，我的波兰父母就是那样对待我的。他们告诉我，这是为了你好。
Around the time Jerzy was 12, his Polish parents decided to send him to an orphanage. They told him it was because they didn't have enough money to keep him at home, but Jerzy noticed they didn't send their other children away. And he concluded that he must be adopted. His Polish family denied it for years, then finally admitted it. So as a teenager, Jerzy started to look for his real family. He contacted a Jewish organization in Poland, but they turned him away. They told him he wasn't Jewish.
在耶日12岁左右时，他的波兰父母决定把他送进孤儿院。他们告诉他是因为家里没足够的钱养他，但耶日注意到他们并没有把其他孩子送走。于是他断定自己一定是领养的。他的波兰家人否认多年，最后才承认。所以作为青少年，耶日开始寻找他的亲生家庭。他联系了波兰的一个犹太组织，但他们拒绝了他，说他不是犹太人。
And what finally ended his search and brought these two people together-- Jerzy and Ida-- was a photograph-- one photograph-- that happened to be published in America.
最终结束他的搜寻并将这两个人——耶日和艾达——聚在一起的，是一张在美国出版的照片。
One day-- it was 1995-- my girlfriend sent me this article from Connecticut, from Jewish Ledger . And she inscribed on top of it, you might find it very interesting. And in the article, there was description of Jewish Holocaust children survivors and the picture of a bearded man, who kind of took me into a little shock when I look at him, because he looked like my grandfather.
有一天——那是1995年——我的女朋友从康涅狄格州的《犹太账本》（Jewish Ledger）上给我寄来了这篇文章，并在上面写道：你可能会觉得这很有趣。文章里描述了犹太人大屠杀中幸存的孩子们，还有一张长胡子男人的照片。当我看到他时，我感到一阵冲击，因为他看起来像我的祖父。
So I was in shock a few months. And finally, one day, I decided I must do something about it. And I wrote to the reporter of that Jewish Ledger . And when I found her, I ask her about this man that she interviewed in Poland. What does she know about him? And she said, actually he does not remember much from his childhood.
我震惊了好几个月。终于有一天，我决定必须做点什么。我写信给那篇报道的记者。找到她后，我问她关于那个在波兰接受采访的人的事，问她了解些什么。她说，实际上，他不记得自己童年的事。
I don't remember anything from wartime. This is like blank something, like, doesn't exist.
我不记得战争期间的任何事。这就像是一片空白，就像不存在一样。
And I thought many times that the reason I do not hear from my brother is probably he does not remember. And I decided I'm going to get in touch with him. So on January 13, 1995, I finally called him. And he said, "Why do you think I am your brother, your twin brother? When were you born?
我无数次想过，我没有我兄弟的消息，可能是因为他不记得了。于是我决定去联系他。所以，1995年1月13日，我终于给他打了电话。他说：“你为什么认为我是你的兄弟，你的双胞胎兄弟？你是什么时候出生的？”
"I was born on May 3, 1939." So he answered, "You're not my sister, because I was born October 15, 1942." So I said, "How do you know for sure?" He said, "Because my Christian birth certificate says so."
“我出生于1939年5月3日。”他回答说：“你不是我姐姐，因为我出生于1942年10月15日。”我说：“你怎么能确定？”他说：“因为我的基督教出生证明上是这么写的。”
So I took a breath and I told him, "Guess what. My Christian birth certificate says the same thing, that I was born in 1942. So there are discrepancies here because we had false papers."
我深吸了一口气告诉他：“你猜怎么着。我的基督教出生证明上也这么写，说我出生于1942年。所以这里有出入，因为我们当时用的是假身份证明。”
So I felt very, very strong about it. And I said, my God, how am I going to convince him that he's my brother.
对此我感觉非常非常强烈。我说：天哪，我该怎么说服他他是我的兄弟呢。
Because you were sure?
因为你确定了？
My instinct told me, my everything. I was already sure. And I ask him, "Do you remember anything from the past? Anything?" And he says, "I told you first time that I did not remember, but now I know that I remember one thing. When I was taken by my Polish foster parents after the war, I was praying-- something that they reminded me all the time-- I was saying, God help mommy, daddy, and Mr. Leon."
我的直觉，我的一切。我已经确定了。我问他：“你记得过去的任何事吗？任何事？”他说：“我第一次就告诉你我不记得，但我现在知道我记得一件事。战争后我被波兰寄养父母带走后，我在祈祷——那是他们一直提醒我的——我说：上帝保佑妈妈、爸爸和莱昂先生（Mr. Leon）。”
And I said, "Do you know who is Mr. Leon?" He says, "No." I said, "That's the name of our father. You were praying for your father."
我说：“你知道莱昂先生是谁吗？”他说：“不知道。”我说：“那是我们父亲的名字。你在为你的父亲祈祷。”
You had been married by this time, hadn't you?
那时候你已经结婚了，对吗？
I married my wife in 1965. And when I saw my wife, after three days, I decided to marry her. And I don't know why til I found my sister. She sent me picture of my mother, you see here? My wife looks similar, very similar, to my mother. And I think [UNINTELLIGIBLE] I remember something.
我在1965年结婚。当我见到我妻子三天后，我就决定娶她。我不知道为什么，直到找到我姐姐。她给我寄了我母亲的照片，你看这儿？我妻子看起来很像她，非常像。我觉得……我想起了一些事情。
Since that time, when we both established that there is possibility we are twins, I cried every day for any little thing. I was so sensitive. I couldn't concentrate at work. And I missed him. I wanted to hear him all the time. I wanted to talk to him. And it seemed like we had like tele--
从那时起，当我们都确定我们可能是双胞胎时，我每天都为一点小事哭泣。我变得非常敏感，工作无法集中注意力。我想念他。我时刻都想听到他的声音，想和他说话。好像我们之间有……
Telepathy.
心灵感应。
Yeah, right. Whenever I thought about him, he would call me. And in the beginning, he called me once in two weeks. Then he called me every week. And toward the end, he called me five, six times a day. It was not enough.
是的，没错。每当我想起他，他就会给我打电话。起初他每两周给我打一次电话。后来每周打一次。到最后，他每天打五、六次。这都不够。
Still, there was no concrete evidence that they were brother and sister. And nothing in the official paper trail suggested that they were related. But Ida decided to go to Poland anyway, to meet the man she believed was her brother.
然而，依然没有确凿证据证明他们是兄妹。官方文件也没有显示他们有血缘关系。但艾达还是决定去波兰见那个她认定的兄弟。
So the final date that we established that I'm going to go to Poland, April 28, 1995. And we met in the Warsaw airport for the first time. And it was like a magnet. From all the people that stood there, I knew which one is my brother. My brother also brought some people from Polish television to record this moment of us meeting. So there were cameras, and we felt like celebrities. And, of course, we had no privacy.
我们最终确定的日期是1995年4月28日，我去波兰。我们在华沙机场第一次见面。那感觉就像磁铁一样。在所有站在那儿的人群中，我知道哪一个是我的兄弟。我哥哥还带了一些波兰电视台的人来记录我们相遇的这一刻。所以有摄像机，我们感觉像名人。当然，我们没有任何隐私。
Wasn't that too bad?
不觉得糟糕吗？
It was a little strange, but I just see my brother, nobody else. I just see the miracle, what happened. And people were standing and crying, not knowing, actually, why we are crying.
有一点奇怪，但我只看到我的兄弟，其他人我都不在乎。我只看到了奇迹发生的时刻。人们站在那儿哭泣，尽管他们其实不知道我们为什么在哭。
First night in our life together, we slept in one room.
我们生命中在一起的第一晚，睡在同一个房间。
But we were talking, all night.
我们彻夜交谈。
And we talk. And in one moment, we started to sing same song.
我们谈着谈着，突然开始唱同一首歌。
Lullaby.
摇篮曲。
And I ask her, from when do you know this song? Because for today, I don't know from when, because I never heard it from my Polish parents.
我问她：你从什么时候知道这首歌的？因为到今天我都不清楚，因为我从未从我的波兰父母那里听过这首歌。
We were singing the same lullaby about two kittens, like twins.
我们在唱同一首关于两只小猫的摇篮曲，就像一对双胞胎一样。
Ida was supposed to stay in Poland just two weeks, but two weeks became four. They just could not stand the idea of being separated from each other. Then Jerzy decided to change his name to Adam Paluch, the name Ida told him he'd been born with. Meanwhile, his family was having trouble adjusting. And his wife of 30 years-- the mother of his children-- started to become jealous of Ida.
艾达本打算只在波兰待两周，但两周变成了四周。他们根本无法忍受分离的念头。然后耶日决定改名为亚当·帕卢赫，艾达告诉他那才是他出生时的名字。与此同时，他的家人很难适应。他结婚30年的妻子——他孩子的母亲——开始嫉妒艾达。
When my sister came, I bring her to our home. And this was understandable for me. I hold her hand. We walked on the street, for example. We talk all the time. And I have no time for my wife. Me and my sister, we have so much information to say.
我姐姐来了之后，我带她回了家。这对我来说是可以理解的。我拉着她的手。例如，我们在街上走。我们一直在聊天。我没时间陪妻子。我和我姐姐有太多话要说。
And your wife was jealous.
你妻子嫉妒了。
My wife, for example, told me, "I don't want you to go to walk without your sister hand with her--
比如我妻子对我说：“我不想让你不拉着你姐姐的手就去散步——
Hand-in-hand.
手拉手。
--hand-in-hand, because people started to talk. You have other woman. Nobody knows this is your sister. And I tell her, "Don't fight with my sister, because you will lose."
——手拉手，因为人们开始闲言碎语。你有了别的女人。没人知道这是你姐姐。我告诉她：“不要跟我姐姐争，因为你会输的。”
His family did not respond the way he expected. When I came, I was the proof that he was a Jew. And they did not want anybody in Poland to know that. They told us not to advertise that we are Jewish.
他的家人没做出他预想的反应。当我来的时候，我是他是犹太人的证据。他们不希望波兰有任何人知道。他们告诉我们不要到处宣扬我们是犹太人。
When I was about to leave Poland, he told me that he would like to meet my family. And I wanted him to meet my family. So he came here as a tourist. He had a visa for a few months. And once he came with me to Chicago, every time we talked about that separation, it was harder to talk. And also, unfortunately, his family got cooler toward him, his wife and his children. They stopped calling him. They stopped talking to him. His wife wouldn't come to the telephone when he called her. Things fell apart.
我快离开波兰时，他告诉我他想见我的家人。我也想让他见我的家人。于是他作为游客来到美国，持有几个月的签证。一旦他随我来到芝加哥，每次谈到那段分离时，谈话就变得越来越沉重。此外，不幸的是，他的家人对他冷淡下来——他的妻子和孩子们。他们停止给他打电话，不再和他说话。他打电话时，他妻子也不接电话。一切都分崩离析了。
I suppose you had a family of your own.
我想你自己也有家庭。
Yes. It's a very good point you're asking me. My family was surprised and felt like they're losing me. Like, what's happening to me? All heart somewhere else. They were not ready for that.
是的，这是一个很好的问题。我的家人很惊讶，觉得他们要失去我了。他们想：我怎么了？心怎么都在别处？他们没做好准备。
I was stranger. And they tried to understand how, in which way I am her brother.
我是陌生人。他们试图理解，我究竟是在哪方面成了她的兄弟。
It was very hard. Even my daughter told me that I'm neglecting her children because of my brother.
非常艰难。甚至我女儿也告诉我，因为我兄弟的缘故，我忽略了她的孩子们。
In Poland, they show, on TV, movie about our meeting, about my life. And they prepare opinion I am bad man because I leave my family.
在波兰，电视上播放了关于我们见面、关于我生活的电影。他们制造舆论说我是个坏人，因为我抛弃了我的家庭。
He was portrayed as the one who left the family, the bad guy. And they were the victims.
他被描绘成抛弃家庭的坏人。而他们是受害者。
And the movie was prepared like that, [SPEAKING POLISH]
电影被制作成那样，[波兰语]
This is a true Jew. That's why he left his wife.
“这是个真正的犹太人。这就是他抛弃妻子的原因。”
There was no way to come back. They didn't make him welcome anymore.
回不去了。他们不再欢迎他。
The truth was, I burn after me bridges.
事实是，我烧毁了身后的桥。
Adam decided to stay in America. He filed for divorce. He'd been struggling in his marriage for years anyway. He moved in with Ida's family for two years and moved down the street from her. He took English classes. But getting a green card was difficult. Ida wrote letters to congresspeople, to immigration officials, to anybody she could think of.
亚当决定留在美国。他提出了离婚。反正他在婚姻中已经挣扎多年了。他搬去和艾达的家人住了两年，然后搬到了她住的那条街上。他上了英语课。但拿到绿卡很困难。艾达给国会议员、移民局官员以及任何她能想到的人写信。
My sister fight for me about almost two years. And this was really fighting. She lost, two times, job because of that.
我姐姐为我争取了近两年。这真的是在战斗。因为这事，她丢了两次工作。
How come you lost jobs?
怎么会丢了工作？
Because I couldn't concentrate anymore on anything. I wanted him to stay. And I felt very, you know, to defend him like a mother. And I have this closeness to him. I have to protect him.
因为我再也无法集中精力做任何事了。我想要他留下来。我觉得自己像个母亲一样要保护他。我和他有一种亲密感，我必须保护他。
Nobody in my previous life took care of me like she.
在我过去的生活中，没有人像她这样照顾我。
Did.
她做到了。
We are inseparable. Every day, we call each other. And now that he lives in his own apartment, we still see each other almost every day. It's very strange but true.
我们形影不离。我们每天都通电话。现在他住在自己的公寓里，我们依然几乎每天见面。这很奇怪，但确实如此。
I cut finger, she cut finger in the same time.
我划破手指，她几乎同时也会划破手指。
In the same place.
在同一个位置。
In two different houses?
在两间不同的房子里？
Yeah.
是的。
Ida and Adam told reporter Anna Lengyel story after story like this, of coincidences that seemed to prove to them in some way that they must be brother and sister, even though no hard proof exists. Their families both agitated for DNA tests, but they refused. To them, they don't need further proof. They just know.
艾达和亚当向记者安娜·连格耶尔讲述了一个又一个这样的故事，这些巧合似乎在某种程度上证明他们一定是亲兄妹，尽管没有确凿的证据。他们的家人都曾坚持要求做DNA测试，但他们拒绝了。对他们来说，不需要进一步的证明。他们就是知道。
There's an uncanny quality when you fall in love. And there's an uncanny quality to finding the home you've never had. And at some level, what is there to say? What makes home feel like home? The fact that it feels like home.
当你坠入爱河时有一种不可思议的感觉，而找到你从未拥有过的家也有一种不可思议的感觉。在某种程度上，还能说什么呢？是什么让“家”感觉像“家”？事实就是：它感觉像家。
You mentioned that you are the two people feeling closest to each other, really closest in this world. So if you happened to have a DNA test tomorrow, which would prove that you're not sister and brother, how would you feel after those--
你提到你们是世界上感觉最亲近的两个人。所以如果明天你们正好做了DNA测试，证明你们不是亲兄妹，在那些……之后，你们会有什么感觉？
We'll be still sister and brother, definitely. A DNA test was already thrown in our faces many times, which in the beginning, upset us. Not anymore. We don't want to prove to anybody anything. We just prove to each other, and that's enough for us.
我们仍然是兄妹，绝对的。DNA测试已经多次摆在我们面前，起初这让我们很不安。现在不了。我们不想向任何人证明什么。我们向彼此证明就足够了。
Anyway, it seems that you were absolutely sure, or you wanted very badly, very much, to believe.
总之，看来你是绝对确定，或者你非常、非常渴望去相信。
No.
不。
No. When I saw her first time in airport, my doubts gone out, away. Immediately.
不。当我第一次在机场看到她时，我的疑虑就烟消云散了。立刻。
You don't really take after each other.
你们长得并不太像。
Well, he is exact copy on father's side and I'm copy of mother's side.
嗯，他完全是父亲那边的翻版，我是母亲那边的翻版。
When I was in Poland, I decide I will not do any blood test.
当我在波兰时，我决定不会做任何验血。
We don't need it.
我们不需要。
And I told to my son, if you need, I will do, and I will close an envelope, and I left it in lawyer office, and after my death, you can open. I can't tell anymore.
我告诉我的儿子：如果你们需要，我会做的。我会把结果封在信封里，放在律师事务所，我死后你们可以打开。我不能再多说什么了。
He'll cry.
他会哭的。
I believe in God. I don't need DNA test, because I believe what happened to us, it has the hand of a higher power.
我相信上帝。我不需要DNA测试，因为我相信发生在我们身上的事，有更高力量的参与。
People who are not touched by Holocaust, they don't understand Holocaust survivors, what every little thing means to us. To some, it might be unimportant, nothing to think about twice, and to us, are very important things, because we'll look for every little piece of evidence.
那些没有受到大屠杀影响的人，他们不理解大屠杀幸存者，不理解每一个微小的细节对我们意味着什么。对某些人来说，这可能无关紧要，不用三思，但对我们来说，这是非常重要的事情，因为我们会寻找每一条证据。
We are already sister and brother when we are Holocaust survivors. We have the same past. We understand each other very well. Not only me and Adam but all the people who are in our group of hidden children and Holocaust children survivors understand each other. You can say one sentence, and they'll finish it for you.
作为大屠杀幸存者，我们已经是兄弟姐妹了。我们有着同样的过去，我们彼此非常理解。不仅是我和亚当，所有我们那个“隐藏儿童”和大屠杀幸存者群体的人都彼此理解。你说出一句话，他们就能为你补全。
Those interviews by Anna Lengyel, a senior producer for Hungarian Radio in Budapest.
以上采访由布达佩斯匈牙利电台资深制作人安娜·连格耶尔完成。
Our program produced today by Alix Spiegel and myself, with Nancy Updike and Julie Snyder. Contributing editors, Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, and Consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help from Jorge Just, Todd Bachmann, and Sylvia Lemus. Marketing by Marge Ostroushko. Research help this week from the authoritative Julie Rigby. Eddy Harris, who I spoke with at the top of our program, writes about his long journey through Africa in his book, Native Stranger .
今天的节目由阿利克斯·斯皮格尔（Alix Spiegel）和我本人制作，南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）和朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）参与。特约编辑：保罗·塔夫（Paul Tough）、杰克·希特（Jack Hitt）、玛吉·罗克林（Margy Rochlin）以及顾问莎拉·沃威尔（Sarah Vowell）。制作协助：豪尔赫·贾斯特（Jorge Just）、托德·巴赫曼（Todd Bachmann）和西尔维娅·莱姆斯（Sylvia Lemus）。营销：玛吉·奥斯特鲁什科（Marge Ostroushko）。本周研究协助：权威的朱莉·里格比（Julie Rigby）。埃迪·哈里斯（Eddy Harris），我节目开头采访的那位，在他的书《本土陌生人》（Native Stranger）中写到了他在非洲的漫长旅程。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
To buy a cassette of this program, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380. Or you can listen to most of our programs for free on the internet at our website, www.thislife.org. Thanks to Elizabeth Meister, who runs the site. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
如需购买本期节目的磁带，请致电芝加哥WBEZ电台，电话312-832-3380。或者，你可以在我们的网站www.thislife.org免费收听我们的大部分节目。感谢管理该网站的伊丽莎白·迈斯特（Elizabeth Meister）。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who greeted me today as he greets me every single day--
WBEZ管理监督：托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia），他今天问候我，就像他每天问候我一样——
Damn. Damn. He couldn't stop saying damn. He was just like, damn.
该死。该死。他不停地说“该死”。他就是说：该死。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。